what do I want to be when I grow up I
mean if I could choose between anything
I would probably be a rock star I'd be
the first haemophiliac international
work
hemophilia means that I'm missing a
factor or protein in my blood
factor eight or factor nine no philia a
is factory hemophilia B Inspector nine
I'm happy I'm Ophelia a and it means
that my blood doesn't clot properly I
can bleed in any joint muscle or organ
every day for me regularly
I take clotting factor and fuse colon
factor in my vein and it helps prevent
the bleeds I mean it's not like I'm
never gonna have them cuz it's it's like
it's no cure it's just prevention but
yeah you shoulda just live with it I am
Adam Stangel I am Zach's dad and I'm
Melissa panna and I am Zach's mom and we
have three other kids too when we first
got a diagnosis it was terrible right
it's it's a pure panic I mean it's
absolutely pure panic initially at the
time I felt absolutely devastating I
mean I felt just like a dark cloud had
come over us it was it was awful
everybody including us have incredible
misconceptions about haemophilia a lot
of people mistake hemophilia for you
know external bleeding papercut gonna
bleed to death but it's really internal
bleeding that's the problem
I mean external I guess can be problem
if I got huge like slash right here but
like typically it's not it's the
internal bleeding that hemophilia is I
remember it's kind of embarrassing but
we had these little ice like ice thing
they like this big they look there was
little ketchup packets and we kept him
in the freezer and he had bruises all
the time right getting learning the walk
fall down bruise and we were to take
these little ice packets and we would
stand over the crib while he was
sleeping and just like put the ice on
these enormous bruises for the lung how
terribly that's ridiculous but at the
time we didn't really have an
alternative and you just want to make
things better a lot of people think I
could do things that I can't and can't
do things that I can't so like once my
teacher said like so in gym I was hurt
my ankle is hurting
hey can I um say out because that's what
I'm supposed to do and he said no you
have to run it out and that's not good
but then one teacher said I couldn't use
a scissor and like a scissor like I
could use a scissor so it's really about
just understanding and I could do pretty
much everything I've been working in
haemophilia since the early 1970s and
was originally involved in cloning
factor 8 and what led on to the
synthetic factor that's now used to
treat hemophilia so I've been able to
follow this story through from like a
more or less complete mystery to
understanding pretty much everything
about hemophilia but now we're on the
track towards a cure very early on I got
the bug for purifying this mysterious
factor 8 we didn't know what it was then
as you can see I'm perfectly fine using
a scissor and eventually we managed to
isolate enough to get its sequence
defined and then synthesized and now
treatment depends on using synthetic
factory so the treatment has evolved
from being very crude and quite
dangerous and partially effective to now
being very effective much more
convenient to give so that patients will
treat themselves can treat themselves at
home and maintain a sufficient level in
their blood that they don't frequently
bleed it's hard to do it with one hand
so don't improvise and use your chin
yeah it's a shot factor is your lifeline
it's not that it's changed their life
it's given that one factor controls how
I live and without I don't know where I
did these are my trophies like this one
and a bunch of these are from baseball
because I like to play baseball um this
one's from Taekwondo I did that for a
while pretty good because he has factor
he's on the swim team he plays Ultimate
Frisbee in school he told us a football
around with his friends
I mean he runs in the running club so
factor Letson do almost everything he
wants to do most people with hemophilia
target joints so joints where they bleed
most and that's my hips they're very
vulnerable so I can't do like bouncy
bouncy stuff horseback riding I can't do
just got to be careful with that stuff
and then the typical like anything will
feel like hockey tackle football
wrestling at it got contact sports I
can't do based on like Taekwondo that's
not like contact sports it's good to be
active to strengthen my muscles so I
don't get weaves and also you're not
strong you know I play a lot of sports I
just have to be careful factor is very
expensive when we say very expensive we
mean that Zack by infusing it costs him
three thousand dollars a day now most
people don't need to infuse every day
Zack does certainly if you have
haemophilia B which needs to infuse even
less than haemophilia a but it's still
extraordinarily expensive so we live
here and we get to decide which brand we
want how often he needs to be infused
and other parts of the world people are
just dying it's calculated by the world
him Philly Federation that four fifths
of patients in the world have suboptimal
or no treatment at all and so we've
still got a long way to go the new
approach we're working on is called gene
therapy the concept of gene therapy is
simple and was first approached over 20
years ago it is to transfer a piece of
information content in the genetic form
be it DNA or RNA into a patient whose
illness is in some way due to a defect
in their information content and
nature's clever trick for doing this is
the virus and they've evolved very
sophisticated machinery for getting into
cells and passing on information content
in the case of a virus the content will
be make more virus what we do is to take
a virus take out its own machinery of
the DNA
that says make more virus and put in a
bit of DNA that says make whatever it is
we want to have mate
in the case of haemophilia one of the
clotting factors then if we infuse that
into the circulation it homes its way in
onto a cell type such as the liver cell
gets into the cell delivers the package
of DNA and then that DNA instructs the
cell that liver cell in this case to go
ahead and start making factor eight the
missing factor and we've shown that that
cures there hema fit it when you say
there's like a test for a cure happening
right what do you mean by that do you
mean like an occasional shot that's just
gonna like cure everything or just like
one little shot but you're done and
never had him a family again
so the idea behind this trial is you get
one shot and that's it you never you
never have to infuse again really
Zack was born in 2001 so it was a period
of time where there was great promise
for gene therapy and I was told by some
researchers that he may be cured by the
time he's in kindergarten within ten
years there's gonna be a cure for
haemophilia i mean i was flat-out told
that by a doctor and then within a
period of a couple of years people
stopped talking about the cure all
together we've been hearing about gene
therapy for from the beginning we if
that's the way it's gonna cure him a
failure then i'm we're all for it that's
awesome but i've been hearing about
flying cars since I was a kid also and
I'm not I'm not getting in one right now
in my 40s right but if there could be a
cure right that would be that would be
great I think that gene therapy was
overhyped in the early days the decades
of technical development that have gone
on quietly have yielded advances that
now give us confidence to say yes gene
therapy is successful now our partners
in industry who are helping us develop
this towards a
the medication that would have approval
are working towards a timeline of 2018
what oh we're having tacos for lunch yes
Oh looks good if we found like a cure
like just someone came to me said we
have a cure at first I don't think it
would affect me too much just because I
could basically do all the things I can
really since I already have all the
medicine I need I'd be basically allowed
to do whatever I want just like I am now
I just wouldn't have to do a shot every
morning I'd probably end up being able
to afford spec writing eventually but
maybe not for me personally but there's
hope for other people who don't have the
factor and stuff because most of the
world doesn't have any treatment so if
there was a cure I could just cure
hemophilia I don't think it would
benefit me as much as it would benefit
everyone who really needs it I mean sure
would be great to have a cure but a lot
of people in the world really needed